guarda tutti ragazzi e benvenuto questo
video sono pro di jake e oggi siamo su
dark souls che sarebbe il gioco di
uomini pelate a non è pelato per sempre
svelato dal fuoco vedo che non è
peraltro venue game salvario game il
razer privi è stato che conferma ditemi
voi se non la più bella apertura di un
videogioco di sempre che io che fabio
che rinfaccia al cesso ma checchia e qui
la festa
mi chiama l'altro ci stiamo divertendo
ragazzi siete contenti come si baila si
mai la pesante qua quanta [ __ ] da
rimorchiare ue la zia come stai
altro che ubriaco mi chiedevo farvi 12
shot per vedere persone kapusta archive
o sta entrando il demonio dai dai dagli
oblò mano e acqua a mali estremi
scarichiamo c concesso se non è successo
è sempre un'ottima soluzione per
scaricarci tutti quanti e sopravvivere
poi non so se il sesso allagato potrebbe
essere un problema in questo caso
ragazze non abbiamo fatto l'incidente di
ponti taniche sono io che ho allargato
accesso provando a riemergere non
riemerge che devo farti sempre stai
calmo già morto bene non era un gioco
semplice questo duck sauce che se togli
una lettera è il dark soul che sarebbe
ciabatte scure light sabic la vita è una
spiaggia e una spiaggia c'è scritto
nella vita alla spiaggia è la barca
quella che stava affondando a sacco
piacere scoprirlo adesso ma io
esattamente dove sono cosa sto facendo e
perché sono qua io sono qua è così
possiamo far partire l'episodio di the
forest ma certa gente ma come ragazzi
siete vivi
allora è colpa mia che ho allagato il
cesso trovavo una medicazione per genere
va bene dottor house dove e quando serve
come li mi hanno bisogno di una benda
stronzo vado in mezzo alla foresta nello
stesso trovare delle band del genere c'è
la torcia figata entra niente ragazzina
tranne che ho vomitato nel cesso ci
siamo schiantati con la barca sull'isola
lost può accompagnare solo grazie ai
ragazzi dell'aiuto siete un sacco utili
alla società soprattutto tu sia non cioè
band e questo potrebbe essere un
problema che siamo qua perfetto io che
andavo in giro per i supermarket siberia
ma in teoria non è messo bene di faccia
e poi ok praticamente gli ha detto se
qualcuno suonando cercare in mezzo alla
foresta dell'acqua fresca perché devo
devo pulire le bende per mettergli e se
qualcuno passa per salvarli non
lasciatemi indietro questo si sono dette
ha scoraggiato qualcuno in particolare
qua ciao cosa cioè i passaggi alle varie
zone nei fatti con le avete fatte col
fumo viola perché quale [ __ ] motivo
spiegatemi quindi lo trovare dell'acqua
ferendola bene qualcosa mi dice che in
questa foresta non troveremo solo
dell'acquafredda potremmo trovare delle
cose mia suocera ad esempio o che culo
questa c'è poi è comunque inquinata
l'acqua della pioggia però sti grazie ai
presa tornare bella animazione che
c'erano anche prima questi cosi
no non c'erano già sticozzi meno del
dubbio me ne vado miss e anche scassata
la torcia che gioia di vivere
preti archi to quickly locali o shoulder
quello più belli livello
la [ __ ] e quando io schiacciato il tasto
io sapevo lo sapevo ha deluso tutti i
personaggi ma tra veramente [ __ ]
ci credono planning e daniele
sapevo che sarebbe successo sta roba da
sei pronta però non ero preparato lo
stesso bene ma il tipo per terra e morto
c'era uno stesso qua prima è morto il
sync el sheikh hassan khan baker escono
mai ho attinto anche faccio veneziani
mesi praticamente stanno dicendo che è
passato del tempo e tipo non è ancora
tornato e morto però non lo sapranno mai
quindi cosa facciamo come in tutti i
fottuti film horror e tutti i
videogiochi di merda andiamo a vedere
che fine ha fatto da soli
ovvio la cosa giusta eco e non di
dividersi e andare da soli a controllare
che cosa è successo brava zia
complimenti giusy che li guardi film va
bene e speriamo che sia morto almeno
decentemente perché non sono poi vedo
che dovevo usare tutti i personaggi
quindi presumo che debba morire anche
questa maghetti si chiama lo chiamano
non ha solo la testa per risponderti
però tu chiamalo sì ciao j non aveva la
testa procedurali forse si sente affatto
dargli tatangelo in cambio ricordo che
per me ho appena detto va bene devo
andare a fare un giro nella foresta
malate rincoglionita forte
sta lì dove ragazzi cei non c'è trave di
1 morto non sai chi è stato cose che fai
andiamo in giro per la foresta certo
genio diari entry colette di una sua 25a
ci sono dei pezzi di ari sparsi in giro
va bene e il gioco qualche brutta
grafica che io abbia mai visto compresa
la più brutta trama io abbia mai visto
tutto brutto è lo sto giocando solo per
una roba le tette di quella di prima
erano grosse ragazzi out la si può
accompagnare solo a te io mi posso
nascondere i messaggi sculli si possa
nascondere invece cespugli fighissimo la
cosa sapete qual è la cosa più
divertente di tutto questo comunque è
che questo [ __ ] gioco costa 14 euro
pd horror c'è solo il prezzo cava cà
layla ma poi fa costa una roba del
genere 14 euro barca va bene essere
almeno outlast per costare 14 euro non
questa merda ho visto giochi tipo heavy
rain costare meno come ho fatto io a
pagarlo soprattutto 14 alla piana
shumpert
mai detto
ma che cazzo sei no no mi rifiuto di
spaventarmi con questa merda
e vabbè però apprezzo tentativo
complimenti c'era un tipo con una noce
di cocco in faccia come fa correre lo sa
solo lui però che i daniele è morta è un
po effettivamente un po di goduria cielo
allora chi siamo stavolta sempre la tra
sfigata questo qua non sa che cosa sia
la [ __ ] credo che non ce la fai
spina roma roma semplicissima se va un
ragazzo nella foresta e ceci crepa balla
balla l'altra ragazza controllare gli
dice guarda che è crepato il nostro
amico vanto da sola nella foresta così
magari trovo del cibo e crepe anche lei
tu non mi puoi adesso dire a e morta
anche l'altra quindi vado anche io nella
foresta cercarla perché sei una
rincoglionita hai dei problemi [ __ ]
può essere così l'incubo radetic
meritate di schiattare tutti quanti male
sono t'ammazza lui ti faccio buttar giù
dalla scogliera di cerbo lanciava
software aggancia posso fare sei dei
[ __ ] dibaba dei ritardi ma
guarda l'aspettato ti puoi nascondere in
dove in queste piantine per terra perché
dopo che nella foglia grossa non si
nasconde nelle piantine piccole si come
com'è possibile con che fisica abbiamo
shampoo che non ragazzi sto gioco non è
noioso e solo diversamente bello per
carità di dio e il 14 euro sono meritati
solo per lo strazio di vederli andar via
dalla carta di credito e quando ti
partono 14 euro per questo gioco qua
urli come se stessi come un jump square
come se ti fosse arrivata in faccia
quello di farina del freddi uguale all
sensazione è la stessa quindi è un
horror che centra il bersaglio
alla fin fine mi sono incastrati mi sono
incastra ma puoi castrati 14 euro
datevi i miei soldi maledetti voi che
vuoi dirmi che sono rimasto incastrato
in una texture del gioco ma questo gioco
questa 14 euro regata che costa 14 euro
e fa cagare almeno fame lo giocare anche
se fa cagare
niente sono continuate a madonna
d'alessio rimini dai di 14 euro o ti
ammazzo
vi rendete conto che sono caduti in una
texture del gioco ma non ci voglio che
non mi fare l'animazione bella quando
esci dal gioco esci da gioco
immediatamente voglio sono incazzato
quindi esci subito andiamo a leggere i
commenti delle persone che l'hanno con 4
giga per nostra con cazzate fatte a far
pesare 40 starhub ascari in pesa 7 hub
della comunità vediamo quanto la gente
contenta aver buttato stesso poi pensate
che vi prende per il culo 14 euro
ragazzi mi è arrivato il sushi almeno
una gioia france uscito ho pagato meno
di questo gioco ma che mi dà più
soddisfazione con ragazzi io concludo
quell'episodio nel caso gli stessi
chiedendo cosa fare se se se se no
fregate su un'isola e dovete prendere le
bende per uno che si è finito quando
andate nella foresta e morite se per
caso poi sfornate nella vita reale
proprio non altro per un'altra persona
non andate dove è morto perché dove
siete morti prima perché no non lo
farebbe neanche un [ __ ] quindi non
lo fate non basta spero ragazzi e che ha
stupito che vi sia piaciuto né il gioco
il video perché il gioco è difficile
anche il video è difficile però cosa se
dovessi se vi sono riuscito il suo al
momento è un mi piace anche vari social
descrizione si scateni ci vediamo il
video mi raccomando nelle foreste non
andate da soli che va bene bella ragazza
[Musica]